let's say that someone's running a
fairly unusual pet store that only has
three types of animals in it it has cats
and we represent the number of cats with
the letter c
it has dogs and we represent the number
of dogs by the letter d and it has bears
that's what makes it unusual and we're
going to represent the number of bears
with the letter b
now this person also tells us that at
this unusual pet store the number of
cats is greater than the number of dogs
which is greater than the number of
bears
now based just on this information they
then ask us which expression is greater
b
divided by c plus d plus b
or
one third and i encourage you to pause
the video now and come up with your own
rationale behind which of these is
greater or maybe they're not maybe
neither is greater maybe they're equal
or maybe you just don't have enough
information from what this pet store
owner told us to actually figure out so
pause the video now
so let's reason through what this
expression is actually representing this
is b the number of bears over the number
of cats
plus the number of dogs
plus the number
of bears so there's the number of bears
over the sum of all the animals so it's
the number of bears over all of the
animals so this really is the fraction
that are bears
the fraction
that
are
bears
now so this this question really reduces
to is the fraction that are bears
greater than a third less than a third
equal to a third or can we not tell and
there's a bunch of different ways to do
this problem and i'll try to expose you
to many ways in in this video and the
next
so one let's do a visual one doing
different cases so let's assume that the
fraction that are bears let's do the
scenario where the fraction that our
bears are greater are greater than
one-third so let's visualize this
so this is if this little diagram right
over here this is let's see this is all
of the pets in the pet store and i've
divided into thirds right over here if
the fraction that are bears is greater
than one-third
then it might look something like this
the fraction of bears so this is a third
under the dotted lines if i want to be
greater than one-third i'll go a little
bit more than greater than one-third
so we go greater than one-third right
over there but if the fraction of bears
is greater than one-third well the
fraction of of dogs has to be even
greater than that
so it has to be at least as much as this
blue area so it's going to be even
greater than that
and
the fraction that are cats has to be
even greater than that and i didn't even
make this one that great so it could
even be you know has to be more than
this blue area and the fraction that are
cats has to be even greater than that
and you see you can't have three things
that are all greater than one-third
adding up adding up to a whole you can't
have all three parts of it being greater
than one-third so this scenario breaks
down another way you could have thought
about it is
if b if this expression right over here
is greater than a third
then c plus d over this has to be less
than two-thirds but that means one of
them c or d would have to be definitely
less than a third in order for that to
work out so at least thinking about this
way you know that this thing cannot be
greater than third let's think about
whether it can be equal a third let's
imagine if this expression the fraction
that our bears were equal to a third
so let's draw let's make our diagram
again
so in this situation
the bears are exactly one-third so i'll
just
color in this third
right over here so they're exactly
exactly one-third are bears
but we know that the number of dogs is
greater than the number of bears so the
fraction that are dogs has to be greater
than the fraction that are bears so the
fraction that are dogs would have to be
greater than one-third
but if the fraction or dogs are greater
than one-third then all we have left is
something less than one-third for the
cats and the cats that's actually the
largest fraction of the animals are cats
so we know we know that this also is not
a possibility so what we're really left
with is that this has to be less than
one-third and let's make sure that
that's reasonable so let's
let's paste another example right over
here so if the blue or if the bears i
should say are less than one-third
are less than one-third
you can uh you can imagine and let me
make it a little bit more dramatic so
that you can
you can make it clear so if this is less
than a third
and let's say
the blue
let's say the the the or not the purple
the dogs let's say they're roughly
exactly one-third
they're exactly one-third then you could
make a scenario where you have the
largest proportion of of of cats
so this would be the cat's right over
here
that's not the same color as the cast
let me do the same color as that pink
color so this right over here is our
cats so this is completely believable c
over
c plus d plus b
c over c plus d plus b does indeed look
bigger than
then d over c plus d plus b which does
indeed look bigger than b over c plus d
plus b so this is completely this is
completely believable to be less than
one-third so based on just this visual
argument that we just made you could say
hey look this right over here is the
larger quantity in the next video i'll
give what i would call more of an
analytical argument where i won't draw
graphs to or our diagrams to show that
this has to be less than one-third